so we know intuitively and we know
because of what happened on January 6th
that there are some Republicans some
portion of the Republican electorate
that is willing to turn to violence that
sees violence as legitimate or at least
Justified uh in order to achieve their
um political goals there's a new study
from the public uh public research
Public public religion Research
Institute that looks very specifically
at who are the Americans that are
willing to turn to violence to achieve
their political objectives and we're
going to look at that right now Salon
summarizes this as an alarming finding
but no surprise many Republicans now
ready to support Violence new prri poll
finds direct links between Trump's big
lie far-right media and support for
potential Violence new public opinion
research
uh the 12th annual American value survey
from the public religion Research
Institute has alarming findings close to
a third of Republicans in the survey 30
percent agree with the statement true
American Patriots may have to resort to
violence in order to save our country
that's more than the combined total of
Democrats and independents who say the
same thing at 11 and 17 percent
respectively let's look at the numbers
we're going to look at some other
elements of this study because it's
really well done really interesting the
question was
how do you agree with the statement
true American Patriots might have to
resort to violence in order to save our
country per party affiliation and
selected attitude so
first of all almost one-fifth of
Americans do believe that true American
Patriots might have to resort to
violence to save uh their country all
right 18 percent of Americans say yes
um the largest group by party
identification is Republicans thirty
percent of Republicans believe violence
may be justified to save the country
what's very interesting is that if you
look at their media consumption the
Republicans who trust mainstream news
only 22 percent believe they may need to
turn to violence of the Republicans who
most trust Fox News the number goes up
to 32 percent believe they may need to
turn to violence and if Fox News is too
liberal
for republicans and they only trust
far-right news presumably stuff like
Newsmax oan and conspiracy stuff then a
full 40 of them forty percent believe
that violence may be justified which is
stunning now
um 17 of Independence and about one out
of ten Democrats also believe the same
and in terms of specific beliefs if you
believe that the 2020 election was
stolen from Donald Trump there's a four
out of 10 chance that you also believe
violence may be necessary or appropriate
um if you believe God has granted
America a special role in human history
27 chance okay so those are very very
disturbing numbers for one very specific
reason there are 30 percent of
Republicans willing to admit in a poll
that they would be supportive of
violence how many Republicans would be
supportive of violence but aren't
willing to admit it in a poll it's some
number for sure and I don't know exactly
um uh what what that number would be but
that's also a significant concern now
there's lots of things to look at in
this study
um just a couple of others in terms of
attitudes and I encourage you to check
we're linking to this check out the
entire study
um one interesting question that was
studied is
has the U.S always been a Force for good
in the world
and has there never been a time you were
not proud to be an American so overall
74 of Americans believe America has
always been a Force for good in the
world
and 58 of Americans say there was never
a time I was not proud to be an American
not surprisingly Republicans are far
more likely to believe that than
Democrats but it's not like Democrats
are slouches the the portrayal The
Stereotype so to speak is Democrats
don't really like the U.S Democrats have
a very anti-American attitude if you
look at these questions it's not that
low I mean sick two-thirds of Democrats
still believe America has always been a
Force for good in the world uh by the
stereotypes of patriotism it's not very
unpatriotic
um okay among other groups
white evangelicals and white
non-evangelical Protestants seem to be
the most stereotypically pro-american
now I say stereotypically because for me
being pro-american means very different
things than it means to these groups but
by these definitions followed by white
Catholics and then Hispanic Catholics
maybe not surprisingly the religiously
unaffiliated are those least likely to
hold these stereotypically patriotic
views
um about the United States of America
um one other thing we we kind of talk
about this idea of idealizing the 1950s
that is prevalent among the American
right and when they talk about
conserving and getting back to when
America was great it's often the the
1950s that they have in mind one of the
questions that this really is a great
study you should you should really page
through it
um
people were asked do you think life has
mostly changed for the better since the
1950s
among Democrats
close to two-thirds believe life is
better now than it was in the 1950s
among Independents about half believe
life is better now than it was in the
1950s only 29 of Republicans believe
that life is now better than it was in
the 1950s and that's very telling when
we think about conservatism what do they
want to conserve what do they want to go
back to and and it seems as though it's
often this kind of 1950s idea it's not
wrong it's not wrong uh not wrong to
believe that
um last thing I want to look at what
traits do you associate with being truly
American and a really excellent question
where you see agreement where between
all Americans Republicans and Democrats
there's not much of a difference are
believing in individual freedoms like
freedom of speech Republicans and
Democrats basically United that is
something that is truly American
believing every citizen should be able
to vote in elections almost exact
numbers between Democrats and
Republicans accepting people of diverse
racial and religious backgrounds you
start to see a little bit of a split
Republicans slightly less than Democrats
believe that
um but where you really start to see
differences is on questions like being
able to speak English is being able to
speak English a sign of being truly
American 93 of Republicans say yes
whereas only 68 of Democrats say yes
believing that capitalism is the best
economic system you see a 27 point gap
between Republicans and Democrats on
whether that is a sign of being really
American believing in God there is a
33-point gap almost 80 percent of
Republicans believe that to be truly
American you must believe in God
less than half of Democrats believe that
um and then uh an interesting one being
of Western European Heritage a sort of
white supremacist belief as being truly
American
one-fifth of Republicans believe that
but almost one-fifth of Democrats
believe that as well okay check out the
study we're linking to it and um recall
of course that when it comes to this
openness to violence to solve political
problems
um recall that Republicans claim to be
about Law and Order until they are not
they claim to be about supporting the
police until January 6th when suddenly
they didn't support the police they
claimed to be about business Freedom
until some businesses started saying hey
we want our employees to be vaccinated
against covet then they weren't about
business Freedom anymore I could spend
the whole show giving you examples but
the point here is they regularly
fantasize about things that they claim
they don't want to see they claim they
want to prevent the collapse of society
and yet increasingly they're willing to
cause it in order to achieve what they
believe will be successful political
outcomes I continue to see January 6th
as a sort of trial for more violence in
the future there have barely been
consequences for the rioters so far
starting to see some no consequences for
the Insiders including members of
Congress Trump staffers Trump himself
and so it shouldn't come as a shock to
us that the number of Republicans
willing or who believe violence may be
appropriate to achieve political gain uh
is as high as it actually is so send me
your thoughts on that if you follow me
on social media you know I love growing
growing my own food in my backyard
garden and our sponsor lettuce grow has
made growing food at home simpler than
ever the lettuce grow Farm Stand is a
vertical stand that can be inside or
outside where you can grow over 200
varieties of fruits and vegetables the
Farm Stand Waters and fertilizes itself
it does all the work for you you can
grow up to 36 plants at a time let us
grow sends you the seedlings and then
your food is ready to eat in four to six
weeks I've had a great experience with
the lettuce grow Farm Stand I've been
growing delicious Tomatoes strawberries
eggplant it only takes up four square
feet fits anywhere I can move it around
very very easy growing your own food is
so rewarding lettuce grow makes it easy
for anyone and lettuce grow is giving my
audience fifty dollars off the Farm
Stand just go to lettucegrow.com Pacman
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below